let's kick things off with a special
edition of Drew love
all right and we invited the best of the
best dating sex and relationship gurus
here to answer all of your burning
questions so let's meet them
um my dear friends from the Girls Gotta
Eat podcast host Raina Greenberg and
Ashley hesseltine are here
ha
and our resident Drew crew dating expert
timona Hoffman is here hi jamona
I am so excited I've been fortunate
enough to do his podcast we've made
friends over the years he's someone I
deeply respect in international dating
and confidence coach who's helped
millions of people let alone women
around the world Matthew Hussey is here
and okay ready for this the OG of them
all renowned sex therapists the one and
only Dr Ruth
thank you
we have Tiani and it's so funny because
I gravitated towards you earlier Tiani
so you have a question for Reina and
Ashley take it away Tiana hi everyone
how are you so I'm someone I usually
FaceTime I investigate a guy before
going out on a date with them do you
guys think what I'm doing is okay or
should I change things up because I know
it could take the spontaneity out of
things so you have to investigate we're
all doing it we all are pre-stalking
someone I think you have to screen
someone I keep getting catfished with
people's voices so I'm trying to get a
voice note from someone or find them on
YouTube somehow pre-screening all day we
gotta be safe out here on these streets
yeah whatever makes you feel comfortable
and safe and confident going into a date
so like Ashley said if you need a
pre-stock do that for me I don't want to
sort of ruin the magic of like let's get
to know each other in person by having
too long of a face time and I love a
face time but after we meet each other
so I don't want to like ruin all of the
exciting treatment that I could learn
about you on the date ahead of time
Demona what's your take well I agree
that you don't want to take the magic
out of it but I would say girl you a
queen and your time is very valuable so
the pre-screening will save you time in
the end instead of just swipe swipe
swiping going right to the date you
gotta know that somebody is worthy
before you show up
Matthew
the uh look you're pre-screening because
you don't want to waste your time
you can mitigate that by just having
shorter dates so instead of giving up an
entire evening to see someone you don't
even know you have a connection with go
for them go for a coffee at lunch time
with them face time's not bad but I
wouldn't make a rule that stifles your
love life
brilliant and Doctor don't even call it
first you have to get to know
the word love I want you to leave for me
never lie I was just leaving sex for you
you talk about acquaintances you talk
about and you have some very good points
about making a decision if that person
has a chance with you or not
now I know that if I would be much
younger
I would have a chance with you
I know that however I'm not going to try
not at my age I don't see a wedding band
I'm engaged though doctor oh I can tell
everybody that you're hungry I am
engaged okay
so
that next year when we do another
television I want to see her with a
wedding band right okay you will
said he said I will see it anyway though
this has turned into you micromanaging
my relationship
micromanage it I would take it from Dr
Ruth Rossi totally because I'm here with
uh Mattel hi by the way and now you have
a question for Matthew yes my question
is when dating when is it the
appropriate time to send those you know
racy pictures The Thirst straps oh a
little sexting how how soon do we do
that I wouldn't send anything to anyone
ever
that you wouldn't that you wouldn't be
happy to see online
you know I think of photos like secrets
you wouldn't tell a friend a secret that
you don't want out there if you're not
sure that person is going to be your
friend five years from now so I don't
think especially if someone's living in
the same town as you you don't need to
send a sexy picture to keep their
attention if you think you do then
you've got to explore why that is
so have you distanced and you're not
going to see them for a while and
they're in your life really in your life
then send them a sexy picture I'm not
talking about a naked picture because I
suggested
never you don't know what life brings
and never never ever to send a naked
picture you know
send a picture that looks like a
passport picture
I didn't think you were going to go to
The Other Extreme
especially the spirit sent a picture
that you don't mind if it's on the air
right that's yes very smart Rayna and
Ashley thoughts so I feel like it's not
a rush you don't need to send all these
things right away you can let the
attraction kind of build and I'm a big
fan of the like subtle implied nude so I
like to imply that I have no clothes on
maybe like you look in the mirror you
put a little blanket around yourself
they conceive no bra on but yeah your
dad could also see that photo you don't
need to send everything right away
um you can save a little bit and yeah
take your time all right to all of you
at home you can join in on the
Valentine's Day fun too just head over
to our Instagram and use our heart
filter to show that you are single and
ready to mingle Ross yeah all right well
coming up will sleeping in separate
bedrooms kill your sex life well you
never talk about that our experts are
going to weighing in coming up
[Music]
thank you
hi I'm Audrey I've been married to Joe
for 66 years I'm Joe and we met in high
school and as soon as we graduated Joe
got draft notice and our parting words
were you do what you want in Germany and
I'll do what I want home and when you
get together we won't tell each other
and it's worked and I guess she did that
I
I don't know the secret is that you got
to get along with each other and take it
day by day
I'm okay
[Music]